the destruction here is hard to absorb
the flags are still flying but dawson
springs has been flattened
because here it isn't just the buildings
knocked over trees have been stripped
cars upturned it is the granular damage
the bits and pieces of people's lives
churned up carried hundreds of meters
the house at the end of elaine drive is
the simpson family home
we found wayne and his son picking
through what's left this was their
daughter's bedroom she was away on
friday night a twist of fate and a
blessing
but they were here they survived they
don't know how
the tv i think the
kind of the alarm of the
the tornado warning and all that woke me
up
uh trying to get to our pets and
everything he woke up and like i said we
got into the bedroom closet right before
it hit
and
if you look at what we have left we're
blessed this this house was well built
and we're just thankful that
that we're so blessed
not everybody had that opportunity
well i wish you both lots of luck thank
you thank you i'm sorry thank you thank
you very much thanks
randy norman is one of the responders
many of them are volunteers but they do
now have help from beyond for an awful
job i'm trying to coordinate uh
the recovery system right now uh
we have quite a few people missing
and uh so we're still trying to or you
can see
uh they could be anywhere so uh
going up into the heart of the
uh the destruction
wow really bad up here
this is pine street
and up at the end they were recovering
what they could
among them joe looney
i woke up in the house was shaking i
hear that like a train coming loud
then the house got shaken violently when
the trailer hit my house it knocked me
out of bed and hurt my shoulders knocked
me over the floor
when i did a two-pour come through the
wall
cut my hand right there
nick my forehead and went through behind
the ship road right across my bed what
knocked me out of
yep i lived there for 26 years
and then 26 seconds have gone
these are the teams searching for the
missing this morning they found three
who didn't make it
this isn't the season for tornadoes like
this and yet it was they say the
strongest on record
the president will visit this week he's
promised whatever it takes
but how do you put all this back
together mark stone sky news in dawson
springs kentucky